mad at me cause i can finally afford to
provide my family with groceries
yeah groceries and two million dollars a
month
in spousal support dr dre's estranged
wife nicole young is requesting
a whole lot of money amid their divorce
according to court docs obtained by et
nicole is seeking one million nine
hundred and thirty six thousand
three hundred and ninety nine dollars
per month
people oh and she's also asking for her
attorney's fees and costs to be covered
totaling 5 million et has reached out to
attorneys for nicole and ray for comment
e.t confirmed in june that nicole filed
for divorce
the two tied the knot in 1996 and
recently celebrated their 24th
wedding anniversary according to the
docs nicole wants the spousal support to
begin retroactively from september 1st
so she can continue to enjoy the
lifestyle she enjoyed
during her marriage attorneys for nicole
claim that she is having difficulty
paying her bills
and that the music mogul who she says
controls all their assets
has been exerting financial control over
his ex
how well nicole's team says dre's team
reviews her bills
and then he decides to approve them or
not while the papers state that nicole
doesn't work
her attorneys claim that she played an
important role in dre's career
that she was integral in naming his
record label aftermath
and should be able to continue the
lifestyle she had before their divorce
and get this the documents also go into
detail about their lifestyle and its
luxury af we're talking five homes in la
a private jet lavish cars
12 security guards seven housekeepers a
private chef
you get the picture anyway apparently
things are getting pretty ugly between
nicole and dre
she claims he kicked her out of their
brentwood house in the middle of the
night in a drunken
rage so she's been living in their
malibu house except
she says he has threatened to sell that
home and allegedly texts her to not
spend
one more cent she also goes into detail
about their pre-marital agreement which
she claims she was forced to sign
under extreme duress on their wedding
day meanwhile forbes reports that dre
was worth
800 million dollars as of 2019.
it's an american dream it's like like i
said it's a
some gods that came from nothing that
created something that's just
amazing that's like bigger than life to
be perfectly honest with you
his fortune is due in part to a
successful headphone line
beats by dr dre which apple acquired for
3 billion
in 2014. but of course the rapper got
his start in the 1980s with the group
nwa
their story was depicted in the 2015
film straight out of compton
this movie really reminds me of the
american dream is that fair to say
uh pretty much so you know it racks the
richest story we just got together and
did this thing and it's really crazy
that
it's um it's just 10 years of my 30 year
career
and they're making a movie about it so
you know i'm i'm
so excited about that man
you